Transcriber: Sara Ozturk
Gözden geçirme: İlker ÖZBAŞ
Keyifli bir sohbet olmasını diliyorum.
Biraz sizleri bugün düşündürmeye
davet etmek istiyorum
çünkü bizim biraz konuşmaya
ihtiyacımız olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Ötekinin yasına ortak olamadığımız,
ötekinin derdiyle hemdert olamadığımız,
başkasının derdine hemdert olamadığımız
gibi başkalarının başkalarının derdiyle
hemdert olmasına da engel olduğumuz,
onları ötekileştirdiğimiz
bir zamanda yaşıyoruz aslında.
Ne gariptir ki benim kendimi var edebilmem
için ötekine ihtiyacım varken
ötekinin derdini çözmesi için
kendisiyle bıraktırmaya çalışıyoruz.
Normalleştirmeye çalışıyoruz,
normalleştirmememiz gereken şeyleri.
Sen halledersin diyoruz, boş ver diyoruz,
bir şekilde yaparsın diyoruz
ya da niye yapmadın diyoruz.
Niye üzerine düşeni yapmadın,
niye alttan almadın diyoruz.
Bunu böyle pandemiden bir örnek vermek
gerekirse pandemi de en çok işten
kimlerin çıkartıldığına baktığımızda
kadınların daha çok işten çıktığı,
bakım vermekle yükümlü olduğu,
kadının bırakacak yeri olmadığı
için bir şekilde
izin kullanmak zorunda kaldığı,
işten çıkmak zorunda kaldığı,
bir kadına karşı
daha çok çalışsaydı diyoruz.
Veya bir erkek ile bir kadın
bir pozisyona gireceği,
bir iş pozisyonuna gireceği zaman
cinsiyetçi bir ayrım yaptığımızda
kadına diyoruz ki daha çok çalışsaydın,
daha çok yapsaydın.
Ama bazı şeyler aslında
hepimizin derdi olması gerekiyor.
Çünkü bazı şeyler birilerinin daha çok
çalışmasıyla, birilerinin daha çok
canının yanmasıyla, birilerinin daha çok
düşünmesiyle veya birilerinin daha çok
kendini var etmesiyle düzelebilecek
şeyler değildir maalesef.
Dolayısıyla bizim birazcık da ötekini
görmek, ötekinin derdini görmek,
ötekinin yasını görmemize ihtiyacımız var
ve çok gerektiğini düşünüyorum.
Aslında bu kadar öteki konuştuğumuz
zaman da pandemiden yani şu anda
pandemiden sonra
nasıl olacağımızı konuşmak için
biraz pandemi döneminde
neler yaşadığımıza bakmak gerekiyor.
Çünkü şeyi konuşmak çok kıymetli,
bundan sonra nasıl yapacağız, beraber
nasıl yapacağımızı konuşmak çok kıymetli.
Ama bu sorunun kendisinde
bile bir şey var.
Yani demek ki bir şeyleri beraber
yapamıyoruz, demek ki bir şeyler
birlikte güzel devam etmiyor,
istediğimiz gibi devam etmiyor
ve biz bir şeyleri
daha iyi yapmaya çalışıyoruz.
O zaman biraz şimdi
ve şu anda geçmişe bakmak gerektiğinin
kıymetli olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Pandemi de ne olmuştu?
Aslında en çok bunu kendimize sorduğumuzda
ya da insanlar bize
yakındıkları noktalarda baktığımızda
dışarı çıkamadık.
Bir şeyleri keşfedemedik.
Bilgiye çok ulaştığımız bir dünyada
birçok şeyi bildiğimizi
sandığımız bir zamanda
aslında çok da fazla
bir şey bilmediğimizi,
çok ele avuca gelmeyecek bir virüsün,
çok da ele avuca gelmesini
istemediğimiz bir virüsün
aslında bizi ne kadar
bir yerde bilgisiz, bir yerde çaresiz,
bir yerde yalnız
bırakabileceğini fark ettik.
Tabii bunu bilmek
ve bir anda çaresiz kalmak,
bilgisizliğin verdiği
bir acıyla beraber kalmak
çoğumuzda bir öfke oluşturdu.
İlk başta aslında kimimiz bunu çok sevdi,
işte kitaplar okuduk dedik.
İlk defa oyunlar oynadık dedik.
Bu bile aslında bir acıydı
ve aslında zaten bu bir yere kadardı.
Çünkü buradan aslında
şuraya gelmek istiyorum.
Biz bir gerçekle yüzleştik.
Bu bizim için bir travmaydı.
Çünkü Lacan der ki, “Gerçek,
simgeselin ötesinde, dilin dışında
ve simgeleştirmeye kapalı
bir alan olarak konumlandırılır
ve gerçek imkansızdır.” der.
Peki pandemi de biz nasıl bir
gerçekle karşılaştık?
Aslında tüm güçlü olduğunu sanan
insanlığın tüm de güçlü olmadığına,
birçok şey bildiğini sanan insanlığın
o kadar çok şey bilmediğini,
çok sosyal olan insanın
o kadar sosyal olmadığını,
ötekine değer vermeyen insanın aslında
ötekiye ne kadar da ihtiyacı olduğunu,
bunu biz pandemide
gerçeğimizi fark ederek
travmatik bir şekilde
deneyimlemeye çalıştık.
En çok yakındığımız yalnız kalmak,
sosyalleşememek, bilgiye ulaşamamak,
dışarıya çıkamamak, ötekiye dokunamamak,
ötekiti buraya çağıramamak
ve ötekine varamamakken
aslında biz ne kadar ötekiyle ilgiliydik?
Yani o çok mutlu olduğumuz hayatlarımızda
hepimizin yakındığı bir şey vardı.
Neydi kalabalıklar içerisinde yalnızlık?
Dolayısıyla ötekileri bir berikiye
getirme sanatıydı pandemi.
İşte bunu aslında ne kadar yapabildik
ve bunu ne kadar yapacağız?
Belki buradan da konuşmakta fayda var.
Şimdi benim için aslında kendimi
tanımlarken ötekiye bakışım
beni değerli kılıyorsa, beni var ediyorsa
ben gerçekten günlük hayatımda
ötekinin varlığıyla,
ötekinin derdiyle, ötekinin
sevip sevmediği, sorun ettiği şeylerle
ne kadar ilgiliydim?
Burada yine biraz
Lacan’dan bakmak isteriz aslında.
Biz ne yapıyoruz günlük hayatımızda?
Nasıl ilişkiler kuruyoruz?
Niye bu kadar koşturmacanın içerisindeyiz?
Bu kadar koşturmaca içerisinde diğerinin
derdini ya da yasını görebiliyor muyuz?
Şimdi Lacan der ki
“Objet petit a”’dan bahseder,
nedir bu, “Benim arzumun
eksik nesnesidir.” demek aslında.
Çok da fazla Türçe’ye çevirmek istemez
ama çevirdiğimiz zamanda böyle bir
çevirmeye geçiyoruz ve şöyle der:
“İnsan doğduğunda dil öncesinde
bir dönemde yaşıyor.
Yani dilimiz yok ve o zaman bize bakım
veren kişi kimse genelde bu annemiz.
Onunla çok iyi bir bağ kuruyoruz.
O bizi seviyor, bizimle oynayan o,
o bizi besleyen.
Fakat biz daha sonra yürümeye
ve konuşmaya başladığımız zaman
ondan gittikçe uzaklaşıyoruz.
O da bizden uzaklaşıyor.
Bu bir yandan tabii keyif verici bir şey
ama bir yandan insanın büyük çaresizliği
ve aslında insanın büyük koşturmasıyla
kendi kendini kaldığı dönem.
Ne demek o? Çünkü biz anneden uzaklaştıkça
büyük arzumuz, yani anneden büyük
arzumuzdan da uzaklaşıyoruz
ve bu bizim her zamanki
arayışımız olacaktır.
Hayatımız boyunca her yaptığımız şeyde o
büyük nesneye ulaşmak isteyeceğiz
ama bir türlü ulaşamayacağızdır.
Nasıl oluyor peki bu?
Bir sürü şey yapıyoruz
o büyük arzumuza ulaşmak için.
İnsanlarla tanışıyoruz,
bir yerlere gidiyoruz,
alışveriş yapıyoruz.
Daha çok yapıyoruz,
güzelliğimize önem veriyoruz.
Bir sürü şey yapıyoruz,
ödüller kazanıyoruz, başarılar kazanıyoruz
ama yetmiyor.
Çünkü Lacan der ki, “Yetmeyecek.”
Hep küçük objet petit a’lara gideceğiz.
Bulduğumuzu zannedeceğiz,
tekrar bırakacağız.
Çünkü bir yandan da şunu söyler der ki,
“Onları bulamamak bir suçluluk doğurur.
O yüzden biz sürekli bunları yapmak
zorunda kalıyoruz.” der.
“Ama şunu da bilmek lazım.” der.
“Bu aslında hiç gidemeyeceğimiz bir yer,
hiç ulaşamayacağımız bir yer.”
Baktığımızda böyle ilişkiler
kuruyoruz aslında.
Nasıl yapıyoruz bunu?
İşte mesela amacım arzu nesnemi doyurmaksa
birisiyle arkadaşsam,
eşim varsa onu kırıyorsam
çok da önemli olmuyor.
Kırmamın sorumluluğunu almıyorum.
İncittiğim birine özür dileme
sorumluluğunu  almadan onunla değersizsem
başka değerli olacağım
nesnelere geçiyorum.
Dolayısıyla aslında öteki beni var ederken
ben hep bir yerde öteki kalmaya
kendimi devam ettiriyorum.
Pandemi de aslında böyle bir şey.
Neden bizi bu kadar zorladı?
Ne ile yüzleşmemize sebep oldu?
Objet petit a’lara yani o nesnelere
koşarcasına gidemeyeceğimiz
bir zaman haline geldi.
İstesek de bir nesne
bulamadık ve bu bizim kendi kendimize
kalmamızdı aynı zamanda.
Fakat bu bir yandan zordu.
Çünkü insanın kendi çaresizliğini,
yalnızlığını görmesi gerekiyordu.
İnsan kendini, bu çaresizliği
görmek istemediğinde
kapıları açtığımızda yine gittiği ilk yer,
sosyalleşebileceği yerler oldu.
Şimdi bunu değiştirmek için
bu şekilde daha iyi bir ilişki
kurmamız çok mümkün değil.
Çünkü ötekinin değerini, ötekinin yasını,
ötekinin acısını, ötekinin kırgınlığını
anlamadığımız sürece kırmaya,
dökmeye devam ediyoruz.
Ve zaten ötekini göremediğim...
Kendimi göremediğim için ötekini
göremediğimden dolayı kendi yasımı da,
kendi kırgınlığımı da, kendi acımı da
hiçbir zaman konuşamamış oluyoruz.
Biz bunları en çok kime yapıyoruz?
Biz mesela bunları en çok
kadınlara yapıyoruz.
Diyoruz ki bir kadına.
Ve onu önce değersizleştirerek çok
değerli olmasını bekliyoruz bir kadından.
Mesela ne yapıyoruz, bunu
en çok beden algısı üzerinden yapıyoruz.
Mesela kadınlara ne diyoruz?
İşte böyle giyinirsen
seni kimse beğenmez diyoruz.
Böyle bir kilodaysan
seni kimse sevmez diyoruz.
Tek tipleştiriyoruz mesela kadınları,
tek tip olduğu zaman diyoruz ki
aferin çok güzel oldun ve oradan mesela.
Ama onun ne hissettiğini,
o kadar değersizleştirildiğinde
bedeniyle yargılandığında
onun ne hissettiğini görmek istemiyoruz.
Yaptığımızla övünüyoruz.
Diyoruz ki aferin bak ne kadar güzel.
Ben sana akıl verdim,
sen de benim sayemde zayıfladın
şimdi seni herkes beğenecek diyoruz.
Değersizleştirerek
değerli olmasını bekliyoruz.
Ne hissettiğini önemsemiyoruz.
Yapmadığı zaman yargılıyoruz mesela.
Niye diyetisyene gitmedin diyoruz,
gittin diyoruz.
Hadi o zaman bir de başka
bir yere git diyoruz.
Sürekli bir alternatif sunuyoruz
ama sunduğumuz alternatifleri
acaba bu kadın istiyor mu?
Bu kadın neyle mutlu, neyle mutsuz?
Hadi bunları gel konuşalım demiyoruz.
Çünkü zaten biz büyürken genelde
bize bu sorular sorulmuyor.
Genelde sorulan sorular ne oluyor?
Niye bunu yaptın?
Niye oraya gittin?
Niye sen bunu yaptın, yapmasaydın gibi
sorularla muhatap oluyoruz.
Elimizde kalanla elimize verilen ne?
Evimizde kalanla
şimdi ne yapacağız sorusunu
genelde sormuyoruz.
Mesela kadınları korkutarak korkmamasını
sağlıyoruz, imkansızı istemek gibi
bir şey aslında ama biz bunu yapıyoruz.
Diyoruz ki mesela bu saatte
burada olmasaydın, onu giymeseydin,
öyle konuşmasaydın böyle olmazdı diyoruz.
Niye babanı kızdırıyorsun diyoruz mesela.
Yani baba gibi bir nesneyi
korkutan bir nesne haline getiriyoruz.
Kadının doyması için bile önce
doyurması gerekiyor mesela.
Yani bir evde abi varsa, baba varsa
ya da bir kadının çocuğu varsa
önce onu doyurmak zorunda kalıyor.
Bir kadının evde bir abisi
ya da babası varsa önce onlara
yemek koymak zorunda kalıyor.
Koymadığı zaman sinirlenen birisi
olduğunda niye onu korkuttun,
niye onu kızdırdın diyor.
Niye yapması gerekeni yapmadın diyor.
Korkutarak korkutmaya çalışıp
korkmamasını sağlıyoruz,
diyoruz ki eve geç gitme yoksa böyle olur.
Kendini koruman için şunu yap,
git o spora, git bu spora diyoruz.
Biz böyle dedikçe ötekinin derdini
kendisiyle çözmesi için
onu bencilleştiriyoruz.
Sorumluluk alması gereken yerlere
sorumlulukları vermiyoruz.
Ama yetişkin olmak,
sorumluluklar almak gerekiyor.
Her şey bizimle ilgili değil.
Her şeyin sorumluluğunu biz de alamayız.
Yine kadınlardan gitmek gerekirse
yetersizleştirerek
yeterli olmalarını sağlıyoruz bir kadının.
Ona şunu söylüyoruz:
Diyoruz ki okuman gerekiyor.
Çünkü okumazsan başkasının eline bakarsın.
Yarın öbür gün
boşanırsan cebinde paran olsun
kimseye muhtaç olma diyoruz.
Yani iyi bir şey yapmasını isterken
bile kötü bir şeyden başlıyoruz.
Bunu en çok kadınlara yapıyoruz.
Çünkü niye bir Aslan Bey’e bunu yapamayız.
Çünkü o bir Aslan Bey, Aslan Bey güçlüdür,
Aslan Bey kudretlidir.
Aslan Bey zaten Aslan Bey’dir ama bir İnci
hanıma biz böyle konuşuruz
ya da bir Su hanıma
ya da bir Tanem hanıma
biz böyle konuşuruz.
Çünkü isimlerimiz bile daha doğmadan
bizim nasıl birisi olacağımızı bize
söyleyen şeylerdir.
O yüzden dil her şeydir.
Kadının...
İçimizdeki mesela kadınlara en çok ne
söylediğimize baktığımızda
zaten burada ortaya çıkıyor.
Google'da araştırma yapsanız
ne diyoruz mesela?
Şimdi bir şey derdim ama hadi neyse
kızsın sen bayansın sen diyoruz.
Benim ağzımı açtırma diyoruz kadına,
kızını dövmeyen dizini döver diyoruz.
Bir kız çocuğu doğsa bir sessizlik
olduğunda ya da bir yerde bir sessizlik
olsa kız çocuğu doğdu diyoruz.
Bizi el alemin diline düşürme
diyoruz mesela kadınlara.
Ama bunu başkalarına
söylemiyoruz genellikle.
Ya da bir anneye diyoruz ki
sustursana bu çocuğu diyoruz.
En çok pandemide, zaten evde.
Evimiz tekinli bir yer olmadığında
bunu en çok pandemide gördük.
Kadın susturması gereken,
kadın doyurması gereken,
kadın giydirmesi, baktırması gereken
ama aslında böyle değil.
Hala babaları yardımcı ebeveyn
konumunda görerek devam edemeyiz.
Bizim eğer bundan sonra
ne yapacağımızı konuşmamız için
buraya kadar ne yaptığımıza
bakmamız gerekiyor.
Daha iyi bir ilişki için
dilimizi değiştirmemiz gerekiyor.
Bizim biraz konuştuğumuza
bakmamız gerekiyor.
Ne söylüyorum?
Kadınlara verdiğimiz sevgide
dahi sevgiyi vermekte bonkör
ya da olduğu gibi
vermekte cesaretli değiliz.
Mesela şimdi seni severdim
ama şımarırsın diyoruz kadınlara.
Bir erkeğe bunu demiyoruz
ama bir kadına seni çok seviyorum
ama söylemek istemiyorum
sen benim ne kadar sevdiğimi biliyorsun,
söylersem de sen şımarırsın
ama sen benim ne kadar
sevdiğimi bil diyoruz.
Onunla yetinmesini istiyoruz.
İşte bu dil.
Diller...
Dilimiz çok şey.
Dilimizi değiştirmek lazım
ama dilimizi değiştirmek için de
ne düşündüğümüzü değiştirmek lazım.
Ne düşündüğümüzü değiştirmek için de
ne inandığımızı değiştirmemiz gerekiyor.
Kadınlar bütün bunları bilirken
zaten çok yoruluyor.
Kendini var etme çabası daha zor bir şey.
İşte bizim ilişkilerimizi
kurtarabilmemiz için
önce ötekinin ne istediğine
bakmamız gerekiyor.
Kendi içimizde ne hissettiğimize
İyileşmek çünkü üç şekilde oluyor.
Aslında tek bir metot, tek bir yöntem yok
daha iyi ilişki kurabilmemiz için
Bir, en önemlisi güvenliğimizi sağlamak.
Ben öldürülmemiş olabilirim.
Ben şu an bugün
bu konuşmayı yapıyor olabilirim.
Ben dayak yememiş de olabilirim.
Ben işten çıkartılmamış olabilirim.
Ama bir kadın güvende değilse,
bir çocuğumuz güvende değilse,
bir birey güvende değilse
ben de güvende değilim.
O yüzden hepimizin güvenliğini
sağlamamız gerekiyor.
Öteki iyi olmadıkça kendi güvenliğimizin
önemli olmadığını artık
anlamamız gerekiyor.
Yani o yüzden aslında biraz pandemiyi
ötekiyi beriye getirme sanatı
olarak da düşünebiliriz.
İki, nasıl iyileşiriz?
Yaslarımızı tutmamız gerekiyor.
Aslında herkes aynı yerden yaslı
yani pandemide zamanımızı kaybettik.
İşimizi kaybettik.
Kayıplarımız oldu.
Çok zorlandık.
Bir yerlere gidemedik.
Kaybımız aynı.
Ben kaybettim.
Önemli değil.
Doğduğumuz zaman zaten ana rahmimizin
en huzurlu olduğu yeri kaybettik.
Herkes önce bu kayıptan başlamalı
ve birbirimizin kayıplarını, yasını,
acılarını ve kırıklarını
konuşmamız gerekiyor.
Ama bunlardan çok uzağız.
Ötekinin acısını görebilmek için
önce kendi acımı görmem gerekiyor.
Canımızın yandığını, bizi canımızı yakan
başkalarına, başkalarına, başkalarına
söylememiz gerekiyor.
Ve üçüncüsü bundan sonra nasıl devam
edeceğimizin belki de en güzel cümlesi
hayata yeniden başlamak.
Bunu yaparken kaldığımız
yerden başlamayı söylüyor herkes
kaldığımız yerden başlayamayız.
Çünkü hiçbir şey aynı zamanda
aynı şekilde devam etmezken
ben kaldığım yerden devam edemem.
Önce kendimi görmek, sonra kendimdeki
ötekiyi görmek gerekiyor
ve hayata kaldığım yerden,
bıraktığım yerden değil değişebildiğimiz
yerden devam etmemiz gerekiyor.
Sevgiyi kullanmamız gerekiyor
çünkü sevgi iyileştiren, değiştiren
ve dönüştürendir.
Bizim biraz da ötekini görmemiz gerekiyor.
Teşekkür ederim.